in the South Pacific at the heart of the  Coral Triangle lies a hidden gem  amid the pristine coral reefs of West  Papua life flourishes above and below  the sea in IMAX you will journey to an  underwater wonderland that you've only  dreamed about home to over 2,000 species  of marine life more than any other place  on the planet  immerse yourself in the splendor of this  remote paradise as its vibrant beauty  comes to life  share the joy of these Islanders and all  those who call this place home  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  join Joey as he takes us on an adventure  through this magical place  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  IMAX entertainment and macula Bri  Freeman producers of Everest invite you  to journey to the South Pacific  narrated by cate blanchett  [Music]